whoa
mirn is a butterfly
yo can't wait to talk about that right
now you're watching podley the official
companion podcast of the show peacemaker
from hbo max and dc and we have a jam
packed show for you today not only are
we going to do our usual breakdown but
we're going to be interviewing freddy
stroma aka vigilante and we have fun i
will just let you know right now buckle
up it's gonna be a good episode why is
there a bald eagle in your car that's
equal eagerly is your pet eagle yeah
is your dog named doggy
all right do you have a daughter named
daughtery
[Applause]
welcome everyone to episode four of
podly the official peacemaker companion
podcast brought to you by hbo max and
dce i'm fiona nova and i'm iffy whiteway
and we're just going to be chatting
about some conspiracy theories ooh some
twists and turns this was like this was
like a twisty episode and also we have
an amazing guest freddie stroma here
we're gonna get some insight on him
playing vigilante
on just like story-wise like how it was
to be this amazing and funny character
oh yeah um and so yeah this is gonna be
a great episode we have so many things
to talk about
[Music]
we're jumping into it let's talk about
it we come off we you know and we're
wondering what happened the aftermath of
the whole like fight between uh you know
them and
and the
butterflies which we learn are actual
but they are actually better what were
you expecting well i you know i thought
it meant like meta you know the
mediterranean that's because you know
from back in episode one yeah he's
fighting her but then now we see this
happen and we have like a lot of
people's going through it yeah yeah
afraid to shoot yeah yeah exactly but i
also feel like this episode has a lot
more like establishing relationships now
oh yeah i know like we have like a
really nice moment with leota and we're
starting to see more emotional turmoil
that's happening in the show um and okay
i know you don't want to talk about it
but i want to talk about that plot twist
that happens
let's talk about that because did you
expect that no not at all but then when
that happened
i was like oh well i guess that makes
sense well to me i don't know like
because now i'm
like wondering the question like is this
a new development yeah is this like did
this happen this episode how long has he
been a butterfly like that it's just
unlocks so many new questions that it
just makes you want to jump into the
next episode yeah yeah yeah because
you're right it's it's it it's like it
kind of makes sense but it kind of
doesn't didn't i wasn't expecting it but
when it happened i think i expected it
yeah because it's weird at this point
we're we're killing the butterflies so
like if he's a butterfly why would he be
in on it so
i'm wondering if some somewhere in this
episode yeah that happened yeah and what
do you like what do you think about this
episode how are you feeling about it i
mean there's like we jumped through like
a lot of things just like we said it's
an emotional episode there's a lot of
things happening it's funny that we are
going to talk to a phrase from a
vigilante because i think we established
vigilante as a badass because you know
he goes he he goes and gets arrested and
they're like oh no
you're dead he's a trained killer he's
not and he
he dispatches three white supremacists
which
white supremacists getting beat up like
non-stop give me the 10-hour cut james
like just but like he's very like funny
and he like just like makes fun of them
and just
kicks their ass yeah because you were
worried for him going into it and then
after that he kicks his ass and then you
know his dad immediately on to was like
nope you're trying to get an excuse to
be able to kill me i'm not saying and
then he slips up by saying you're a bad
dad which you know sometimes the truth
hurts the truth and it needs to be said
he cares about peacemaker exactly like
he went in there four people like he's a
good friend yeah yeah he's a sidekick
that i would have liked yeah because i
feel like that makes it sound like you
had a psychic that you didn't like
yeah maybe i haven't you don't know that
okay you don't have to cut me out like
that yeah sorry i didn't mean to expose
yourself don't expose that don't expose
my secret i know that weird voice
well he has to do what he has to do i
guess
i took it you vigilante
no you sound like him
no we don't
that's a fake voice
nope
it changed from what it was two seconds
ago i was about to cough
but yeah this this is more my real voice
right
to me he is so
believable as a person who wants to be a
hero who's not it's grounded in some way
right yes me in so many ways like that
that person would be super hyper focused
into hiding his identity yeah yeah well
i mean like we talked we're going to be
talking to freddy's drama and i mean
vigilante it seems like would you think
this episode was probably his
his spotlight time well i think we
he got a nice spotlight in this but we
also get to
get deeper into peacemakers yeah
something we you know we gotta really
consider is like we're coming into this
show after peacemaker is kind of the
revealed big bad at the end of the
suicide squad yeah yeah yeah so like
there's a lot of work that james is
doing in this show to kind of like
kind of give us some backstory kind of
like win peacemaker over as like a hero
and i think we've seen it at this point
we're understanding where he stands or
like how he became who he is at the
moment how about like judo master
escaping i mean we've been new
oh yeah i mean we've been new i don't
think this guy's like so op i know it's
so it's so funny because the every fight
scene with judo master is so fun and
just ever since you just see him eating
those cheetos
cheetos are such a nice touch and it's
just sassy so sassy doesn't want to
share the cheetos oh i'd say yeah i love
it yeah i think this episode was great i
definitely want to talk about that
quantum unfolding storage area yeah so
one you know we got a little taste of it
but we didn't know exactly what it was
when you know peacemaker picked up some
new helmets yeah but a lot of a lot of
big bombs were were dropped when we went
in there i mean one we get the the fact
that how it works and because it's so
huge inside that means that's a whole
arsenal we and i and i don't know how
much of it we're gonna get to see this
season but that
is a bunch yeah but the other huge
reveal is that his dad
is the white dragon which is a dc comics
villain that's a real villain a super
powered member of the kkk uh just out
on full racism mode he was in the
suicide squad himself in the comic books
so what i like here you know just from
like um actually nerds out there is you
have james weaving the peacemaker story
with the white dragon because the comic
book peacemaker has this kind of uh this
reckoning with the fact that he was
raised by his father who was like this
nazi guy
so james are combining these two lores
to make this like new super powered uh
you know story that is even more
exciting right so and do you think it's
like like since we saw that part of the
white dragon
like do you think he's going to be kind
of like this really big threat do you
think he's a big bad in this i don't
know if this is the season's big i mean
we're going to be one of them yeah yeah
all these butterflies
you dust that bad boy off and you put it
on you squeeze yourself in there i mean
you make a good point nothing was dusty
uh in the
storage area so yeah obviously it's been
used the atoms or something atoms are
this good ventilation or something in
there because those those helmets are
still shiny there's no not a speck of
dust
it is kind of just a powerful thing so
who knows maybe it's dust repellent
so i feel like it's not the he's not the
big bad of the season but he is one of
the big bads so he's going to be this
kind of threat to peacemaker and the
crew i'm i'm ready okay well listen we
got freddie stroma here who's gonna
we're just gonna get some insight on
vigilante as a character how he liked to
play it and just some other things that
we could talk about i'm going to ask him
all kinds of questions he's going to be
he's going to be bitching to leave yeah
yeah he's going to be like please no
more yeah and uh let's just ask him some
questions so freddie stroma
[Music]
hello everyone we are joined by the
lovely freddy stroma here we're so
excited to talk to him i mean we've got
a bunch of questions to ask him but i've
got to ask freddie this was a pretty
this was kind of like an unexpected
emotional episode
how did it feel to act in such like an
emotional and vulnerable state um i mean
for me uh adrian or vigilante was um
it wasn't too bad like i i kind of i had
maybe that you know there's one scene uh
with jen that you know in the car but
that's
i actually you know i didn't even know
to the level that you know when we were
shooting on the day james kind of was
like okay so we want to bring it to here
and he kind of showed me the montage of
stuff that he'd shot i was like oh wow
this is this is some emotional stuff um
but other than that scene it wasn't
really too
much for me i got to just have a lot of
fun you're just a natural you could say
that yeah
because it definitely felt that way
especially because like the adrian you
know version of vigilante you're playing
has like kind of a dark storyline in the
original source material and like you i
feel like you carry that weight almost
so much that i was like so afraid for us
what was gonna happen don't i i love him
yeah it's a it's a funny thing he's yeah
he's just so kind of you just have no
idea what he's gonna do what he's
thinking which is always fun to play you
know there's just so many different
levels that you just it's fun to be in
that place where you just have no idea
what he's doing yeah and and so it's so
since you're massed up the entire time
what um like do you do your own stunts i
mean obviously we you know you can lie
we won't know but
well i will say so for any of the stunts
that you see that are like insane
definitely not me
there's you know there was some stuff in
episode four um i got to do a lot of
that fighting i think a lot of the stuff
from what i've seen is me uh is kind of
my stuff but we had such a like an
insanely good stunt team and they you
know they perform it all as well and
then they can kind of use um bits and
pieces but it's always good to try and
get the the actor's face in there you
know it's not too obvious
i i guess you know uh you've had some
serious in-depth
you know uh questions about the
performance and acting i i think minds
is of the same you know caliber
uh and i want to ask
how do you feel
a duck would uh
would disguise itself as a human like
what would you have an amazing question
if a great job we love to hear it if it
walks like a duck it's all i'm saying
the [ __ ] that supposed to mean if it
walks like a duck it's either a duck or
a duck wearing some type of human
costume i don't know he's unable to hide
his distinctive walk how the [ __ ] could
that even happen how would what happen a
duck in a human costume the sizes are
completely incompatible i don't know
ducks are sneaky i guess i guess that's
the whole point of the phrase that and
they could give two shits about their
best friend's pinky toe
you know what there is actually a very
obvious duck that is masquerading as a
human um and he's doing a terrible job
because if you go and you win
23
gold medals and swimming yes and then
you're trying to claim that you're a
human yeah yeah michael michael phelps
is a duck yeah michael phelps exactly
right especially with the wingspan being
longer than most humans i'm like that
that's just a wing that man can fly yeah
yeah that guy he's he's he's you know
duck or you know water or he's just he's
he's too fast too fast that guy is too
fast for his own good yeah well so in
the episode it seems like i just want to
ask because
if you were to break into a jail what
what do you think you would do
um well obviously nothing
nothing bad that would happen nothing
bad
maybe i'd start like a food fight in a
in like a
in a food hall maybe it would have to be
pretty violent to get arrested i feel
like you will get you will go to jail
honestly i was a big fan of the way you
as vigilante did it in the show because
you know we've all had that scenario in
our head where we were like if someone i
want a beat up is in jail and i need to
get in jail
maybe a couple days you don't want like
a full prison break scenario where
you're fighting god
yeah
yeah you're like oh well you're actually
gonna be in it for like a good few years
oh crap
oh that backfired
yeah yeah
we all know that of course vigilante is
a superhero but if you were a super
villain
who would be in your culture
of uh coterie cultury
curtery of super villains we were
looking up that word with freddy and i
was like i need to hear how it's yes
yeah because you were gonna like over
pronounce it i was gonna over pronounce
it absolutely and that's kind of like i
guess the people that i'm trying to
you know i'm fighting against my like
the worst super villains you know the
you know when you land in an airplane
and then
you're supposed to stand up and then you
get someone who stands up and then they
just start walking down the aisle trying
to get a few seats ahead oh i feel you
he's on my list yes
good one good one um the guy who you
open a door you know
people go through and then the person
who's on his phone and then doesn't
acknowledge doesn't say anything he just
walks through no thank you that guy he's
on the list he's on the list
and uh hitler yeah
yeah good answer and if you didn't say
that i would have been like well hold on
let's redo your list real quick there's
some other people
and other other black people who don't
return the head nod you're on my
supervisor
you're absolutely nodded you're right
there's a secret agreement we have and
you don't knock back you're working for
this
[Laughter]
you're right yeah yeah yeah they're up
to something yeah yeah yeah they're
butterflies
they're butterfly well speaking of i
mean i mean there's we have a question
for you but i think if you should take
it because you you were talking about
this scene that you really loved it was
your favorite scene of the episode you
know you know we you know i know you
were acting but your what is your your
favorite contribution made by black
people we would love to know especially
you know you know someone from over the
pond so you you know yeah you came out i
mean i would probably i mean kind of
what vij was saying like i'd like that
that's the influence on music just to
bring in blues and jazz and to just like
add the what is it the third the fifth
and the seventh and then to just
completely change the landscape of music
yeah um and then that affects you know i
mean it was uh i think
i think muddy waters came over to the uk
and had a huge effect it just changed
everything and now it's all that i
listen to i'm sure looking into this
in my room but like it's pretty much
mostly what we listen to and i can't
like that i personally
gained from every single day by
everything i listened to
that's a good that was a good idea
you know i'm definitely gonna send you
your ally medal um
um well okay speaking of music john cena
does this like kind of sad dance
um and we love we loved it because it
was great oh yeah uh but we wanted to
know like what's your go-to
sad track or sad song that you like
listen to and you're just
you're just bummed out you know i mean i
want to say wicked game by chris isaac
um because it's just
it's just ridiculous well i love it it's
a great song i'm not i'm not mocking it
it's just to me visually that's a great
one to just okay um
but i mean i think sometimes there's a
song outro by m83 or m83 um that i
sometimes i listen to like you have to
like i do know yes like an emotional
scene like that gets that gets me going
though but that's like a legit one you
feel like the main character yeah you're
listening to it and you're like oh but
also a minute yeah we got some insight
so when you got an emotional scene
you'll kind of listen to music and
and get yourself yeah if you need to if
you need to get to that place and like
you know sometimes the past your
different roles you know if you have to
really get to like uh you know oh yeah
the emotional spot sometimes music
really helps just kick start everything
i feel that and like i i think i had
this other question that i kind of want
to know like how
how do you feel playing vigilant did you
know a lot about that character
beforehand or like how do you feel to be
him like really it's i mean it was it's
tough because he's had so many different
iterations like him he's been a cowboy
he's been a lawyer he's been he's been
so many different things and so it's
it's um at the end of the day i kind of
had to just go with what was on uh what
james had created um and so you know and
i got uh the eight episodes in one which
is very rare in tv but james is a
writing beast and he just had it all
done yeah um and so uh like i got to
just go off what he created like a lot
of the other stuff wouldn't have worked
um
it was just a different character so
it's his kind of interpretation that i
was i was going off of you you're like
killing it as vigilante i'm like i think
you're like the perfect fit you did
you're doing such a great job
being him yeah and
the heart you bring to the character you
just want to especially like what i find
that's fun about the way you and john
play off of each other is i feel like
y'all are are kind of the same but from
different spectrums where you know you
have this like earned like you trying to
be this good person but you
are just
just murderous
and it feels like he's on the side where
like he comes from this like evil but
he's trying to be good so you all are
meeting in the middle and y'all i just
truly so many times have just bust out
loud laughing
yeah yeah
it's a lot it's a lot of fun i mean it's
and james is i mean james's writing is
what that's it's all it's all from there
and just every time i mean i read it i
was just laughing as i would read the
script and then you get to set and then
he gives you different alts and then
you're laughing even more and it's just
ah
i can only imagine the amount of
laughter and just like oh yeah breaking
of character that would happen like
during this entire show so yeah i would
have immediately broke when you started
making those faces when you're mad
oh man james we was like i need you to
make the most embarrassing faces you can
make and i was like i've kind of like
i've sort of trained for this my whole
life i've always like i remember doing
when i was a kid with my sisters like
who could make the ugliest face and i
would just we'd always try and make
stupid faces and i was like well i've
i've uh i'm i'm trained for this moment
i was like i'm just i'm giving it
everything i got so
i'm sure there'll be some some gifs or
gifts that'll come out of that one oh
yeah oh yeah no no that that will be
prepare to see that for the rest of the
year
i
i
actively have the gift ready to go once
they say we can talk about the show yeah
absolutely oh god all right so freddie
vigilante is like maybe possibly the
funniest character yeah yeah it's really
it's like neck and neck yeah but um i
want to know like what is your comedic
timing and are you are you funny
no no not at all i am no i it's funny i
am i do have like i kind of looked over
my career and started realizing that
like i'm mostly in like
comedies or rom-coms and
there's like a there's there's kind of a
through line um but i kind of i got to
experiment a lot about a year ago i got
i did my first live studio audience uh
it was a show called the crew on netflix
and with kevin james and we did like i i
got to really you know try that out um
and it was
uh eye-opening and just really really
fun um and then i mean i i'd like to say
that it's
you know my comedic timing but when you
get the script that james uh writes and
then you've got
um john is just incredible yeah
and such an incredible um
improviser and
then you've got james throwing out even
funnier alts like over the mic like
while you're well you're rolling and
doing different takes like it's a lot of
those guys is what is what makes uh
vigilante so funny
yeah i mean i feel listen don't don't
put yourself down i feel like you might
be funny actually yeah i mean it's hard
to do comedy yeah you've you've uh
you've got the track record to prove it
you do you've got the there's a reason
you keep getting picked for these yeah
okay i'll take it yeah take it take the
compliment i would
all right before we go we have one last
question for you which of course we had
to get it through the eagley mail
email
[Music]
all right okay so this one uh this one
is a question reaction from the
community and uh this one uh today is
asking about some personal growth and
development
peacemaker seems to be a story of
personal redemption and despite one's
imperfections trying to become a better
person what are the personal flaws that
you've overcome or are working on
overcoming oh wow
anyway would you expect this to be a
therapy session freddie
yeah
oh i did not i did not um okay i feel
like i you know procrastination is
something i'm constantly battling um
yeah so you know it's it's the it's the
you know don't take the marshmallow wait
15 minutes to get the other one um it's
just i you know that's like something
i'm always battling and i think it
spreads to all aspects of life that's
probably the thing that i'm always
battling which i think most humans are
but um
you know
i'm not gonna make a movie about it like
the guy on the couch he's like
should i not play this game on my phone
find out next week like you know it's
just not uh
um yeah that's probably my uh main
battle
um personal growth well you know
hopefully seeing james gunn crank out
eight scripts uh before he's
will help you get over procrastination
yeah
whatever procrastination james has the
opposite yeah he has the opposite he can
just create like absolute gold and he
can do it in like like a day he he'll
just pump it away
yeah yeah yeah
well freddy thank you so much uh we
loved having you here chatting with you
you are killing it
and you know we've said it this entire
time but seriously you are and we're
loving the show so thank you for
spending your time with us yeah thank
you thanks for having me yeah we'll chat
later yeah yeah i want some funny jokes
from you later
i'll send you that invite to my improv
group yeah exactly
so you'll get that in the mail as well
yeah we'll see you later freddie all
right see you later thank you the big
hand is on the three so you know it's
time for another peace prize for episode
four
[Music]
what you got what you got bubbling up i
feel like the leota and peacemaker scene
yeah i think you're right because you i
mean especially like we said we start
off with leota kind of coming to terms
with the fact that she that she couldn't
kill someone and in that same moment you
had peacemaker afraid of that too so
they they are more similar than they
think yeah and to have this moment where
she's able to get through to him in a
way i don't think we've seen anybody
able to get through to him this whole
season yet
uh by kind of tapping into what we're
slowly learning might be a suppressed
memory uh yep that is very true and i
mean it's it's an emotional i think like
just like we said before this episode
kind of carried its emotional weight or
getting to know the characters more
their the relationships between them and
i think we've always kind of hinted at
leota and peacemaker kind of being that
duo and relating to themselves i know
peacemaker like trusts her so the award
of the week the eagley hug award goes to
the scene between leota and peacemaker
outside the prison so good so warm and
so wholesome i think it deserved it yeah
we love emotional turmoil yeah it feels
like an eagle it feels it feels it feels
like an eagley hug i can't just abandon
him in there
i have to go talk to him do you really
look we all know what he's done to you
you don't know [ __ ]
we do
it's in your fouls chris
it's chris now
how he's treated you your whole life
what's it say well we all want to
believe that our parents are flawed but
innately good and maybe usually that's
the case
but not here your dad is not a good man
not to the world and especially not to
you
still family
chris
it was great yeah i think that was a
great scene and i just think danielle
brooks is like
an amazing leota oh she just kind of
nails it well just uh just such a like
stellar actress and like i said i've
been i've been on the brooks train since
we've been on the train for a while yeah
and so
like to see her really like show out uh
the way she has in this series it's like
great yeah like every everyone's gonna
be trying to cast her and i'm so excited
for that a warm eagly hug is what we
call it
the ugly hug award right before we
witness vigilante go break bones
that's that's the show yeah
and if you want to get tapped into the
source material make sure you sign up
for dc universe infinite which will give
you access to all the peacemaker comics
suicide squad and everything in between
and we've got some sweet merch go to
shop.dcomics.com for the latest drops
you don't want to miss it also don't
forget to go ahead and follow us on
twitter instagram and facebook and make
sure you comment and tell us your
favorite moments from the episode solid
and make sure you stream new episodes of
peacemaker and our podly podcast on hbo
max okay see you all next time i'm iffy
whiteyway and i'm fiona nova catch you
next week